would you say you're adept at technology
because i have found in this time of
quarantine you got to be pretty good
with computers you got to be able to get
on zoom
are you able to do all this stuff no i'm
doing pretty good i'm doing
you know i love what i do the new um
this new age is technical
and i'm really like tick tock time
because i do stupid stuff every day and
i just want to
you know i want to put on tomorrow i'm
going to put on tick tock
trump going to jail trump going to jail
and then it's a dance craze yeah yeah
but
i shouldn't have said that because i
don't i don't do trump jokes anymore so
you know
by the way we need to have a garage sale
too because they got all these trump
jokes around here stinking up thing i
need to get rid of them you know i've
been happy
not talking about him i have to say
um i know that some comedians say i'm
gonna miss doing the trump jokes and i
think
i i mean i tried to not talk about him
even the last year of his presidency i
just got tired of it
and so i'm enjoying i'm enjoying this
time i think it's going to be a good
time for comedy
actually i don't know about that i don't
know about that i mean i'm doing right
now with
it with the last week what has happened
in america
on the 21st i felt like a a freed slave
you know
i just felt just great and then i have
uh
of course i'm democrat i was from biden
but biden uh
i like him but i don't like it i mean
this guy is i mean he's doing some great
stuff but
it's not good for us comedian i got no
joke on it
i got no joke on fighting you know what
that was the same
you know i remembered us talking about
this when obama was president
he was he was tough for comedians
because he's this
uh handsome smart uh you know
uh competent uh man who's working hard
to make the country a better place
and um you know where's the joke in that
but i think
out but you know what i'll say as a
patriot
i'll take the competent president over
the jokes and if it means that my
business suffers
so be it my business does not need to
suffer i'm having problems with fighting
he walks in there yesterday using his
four-letter word
plan now when the last time we heard the
word
it's been four years i mean that's good
with the plan but it ain't funny
that's not funny he walks in with his
cova team yesterday
doctors scientists epidemiologists
infectious disease specialists with a
plan
well he didn't come in with family
members and some guy
push a pillow with mypillow.com guy
i mean i mean it's good
you're right this is a terrible terrible
time for american comedy
and money you know he's doing that and
this guy look at him what he's doing
to top all of that off making full
complete sentences when the last time we
heard that
he's i like him but it ain't funny yeah
yeah you're right we got to get
we got to move him out uh it's it's he
hasn't been on a golf course
it's been a whole week
how are you supposed to run a country
and make a country
better without being on the golf course
you know freeing your mind
but it's not funny well i'm sorry
i'm i'm sorry you're right this is a
terrible time terrible time for our
country
you